- On this episode,
we do a call-in show again
'cause that's the only
way we do the show now.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- What is the intro do this?
Help me, I'm not joking.
Hey everybody
this is episode 241,
do I go that route?
- [Other Tyler] Hey everybody,
it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this episode 241 of--
- Okay, thank you.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 241
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
We've been calling in,
it's been going well.
I'm excited, it's a nice day.
There's a lot going on.
There's all
Periscope, Facebook,
Instagram we are
bringing it live hard-core and,
I don't know if you guys have
been paying attention to the
YouTube numbers,
I'm sure all of you have,
The #AskGaryVee
call-in show kills.
People are
excited for this show.
It's quality, it's good and
I love the call-in nature.
It's allowing me to go deep so
right now the way we've been
taking the numbers if you don't
follow me on Instagram
you're making a huge
mistake because that's
where we get the numbers from.
That's where Chris
is doing his thing.
You ready? Alright, hit it.
(phone ringing)
Here we go, first caller.
Excited.
- [Sebastian] Hello?
- What's the name?
- [Sebastian] Sebastian.
- Sebastian, this is GaryVee and
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Sebastian] Yeah, baby.
What's up, Gary?
- Life is good.
Where are you from?
- [Sebastian] I'm
from Jersey City, man.
- I love it, the Jersey love.
What can I help you with?
- [Sebastian] Oh man, so I have
this company called Sexy Nerds.
- Sexy Nerds.
- [Sebastian] We are the
premiere nightlife event for
geeks and nerds.
- Okay.
- [Sebastian] Oh man,
my heart is racing.
- No, don't worry, don't worry.
Get into it 'cause this is a
huge opportunity for Andy K,
who's a huge nerd and
he love nightlife so--
(group laughter)
- [Sebastian] Huge nerd
and huge sexy one.
- That's right.
- [Sebastian] What's up, Andy?
- There you go.
- [Sebastian] Actually, you got
a whole crew of sexy nerds out
there, yourself
being the leader,
I already know.
- That's true.
So, talk to me. Yep.
- [Sebastian] So we're
in the nightlife space,
I've thrown a successful
parties the last six months
in New York City.
We're about to
expand to Toronto.
I want to get into
the e-sports field.
We have huge
points on nostalgia.
Our parties are '90s themed.
We bring out Nintendo 64s,
crazy video games,
cosplay,
it's like a mini ComiCon.
I guess my question to you is
I'm reaching a point where I'm
funding this on my own as an
individual and I feel like I'm
reaching this ceiling where I
feel like I need money to expand
but at the same time, I just
don't want to take money silly.
- Who owns it?
- [Sebastian] Me, 100%.
- My intuition is that if
you found a sales driven media
person and made them your
business partner who is 10 years
your senior and gave
them 10 to 20% of the company,
you could explode.
Somebody who's got a Rolodex
that can get a brand that wants
to tap into this audience.
If your parties are going off
like that and you've got the
momentum as the creative
director and entrepreneur,
there's beer brands,
there's all sorts of brands,
you know, Frito-Lay, there's all
sorts of brands that you could
probably rack up a nice little
six-figure revenue business just
based on the Rolodex of some guy
or girl that works at Omnicom or
Starcom or Ogilvy.
- [Sebastian] Absolutely.
- This feels like the
exact example of not about
money but about partner.
- [Sebastian] Right, okay.
- Everybody right now is
thinking about money. Right?
Everybody's about
raising capital, smart money.
- [Sebastian] Right.
- I'm the smartest fucking money
you can get but I'm not gonna
help because I'm busy.
So my $100,000 is smart but I'll
talk to you like four times.
I'd rather you get smart
partner instead of smart money.
So I would go out and get a
sales man or woman who works in
the media space.
The way you interview
them is you go into Meetup.com,
you hit up people on LinkedIn
who work at Mindshare and
MediaVest, at these media buying
agencies who have Rolodexes
to agencies and brands.
- [Sebastian] Okay.
- And who from Day 1 are into
this concept and you can build a
very nice event marketing
business predicated and easily
this is a seven-figure business
if your parties get big enough
and you can
have a sponsor brand.
I mean this is a real thing.
Nightlife activations, event
marketing is real business.
- [Sebastian] Absolutely.
- But the people that make the
most money are the ones that
sell ahead of where they're at
and that's not fake it 'til you
make it, that's hey give me
money to be a sponsor and I'll
give you a two year deal and if
you believe in me and I deliver,
you're gonna steal the
sponsorship from me because over
the next two years
it'll be worth way more.
- [Sebastian] Wow.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Sebastian] I see exactly
where you're going, homie.
- You're the marketer
and the creative director.
You need somebody who can
subsidize the sales funnel and
the biz dev, that's
the partner you need.
- [Sebastian] Excellent,
excellent.
And myself being in a
sales background,--
- Well then maybe you
need the other person.
- [Sebastian] Right, right.
I do need that somebody who's my
senior or like 10 years down the
line just so I know
where I'm expanding
I'm just kind of in the forest.
I can't see the
forest from the trees.
- Experience, the biggest
mistake kids are making right
now is they lack experience.
- [Sebastian] Right.
- And so, what they're doing is
they think VCs are gonna give
them that, VCs and
Angel investors are
gonna give you money.
They don't have time.
What you need is an
actual grinding partner.
This is the biggest mistake
kids are making right now.
Everybody thinks
that they can just do it,
and by the way, maybe you can.
But if you're calling in,
looking for advice and it feels
like to me that
that senior partner.
There's so many 33-year-olds
that hate their job,
made a couple bucks that are
looking for that
business, find 'em.
- [Sebastian] Wow,
that's great and Gary,
while I'm looking for
these people any idea in
terms of the e-sports play?
Any sort of sweat equity
I could build in everything
that we're talking about?
'Cause I'm
looking for the money,
I'm looking for the partner
but I'm also looking to bring as
much to the table myself
so that I can keep as much
in the long run.
- What do you mean by sweat,
what do you mean by that?
Like, who are you
looking to bring on?
- [Sebastian] Yeah, I'm actually
looking to assemble an e-sports
team and using their social
capital and the allure--
- Yeah, now you're talking
about a totally different thing.
Now you're talking about,
you just said to me,
hey, I've got a donut
shop but I'm also gonna
start a junkyard business.
They have nothing
to do with each other.
I get that
there's some retro shit,
but you're making it
conveniently fit in because you
believe in the e-sports things.
You're getting into a
whole different business.
Can you drink out of two hoses
in a world where one hose is
overfilling your mouth?
That's the thing
I would debate there.
- [Sebastian] Fascinating,
fascinating.
Thank you so much.
- You got it, brother.
- [Sebastian] If I ever get an
opportunity to buy you lunch on
Resy, I'd love to do that.
- Thank you.
- [Sebastian] And peace
and love.
- Thank you.
You too, brother.
Make sure you get me the name.
Yeah, I think the theme of that
call is very simple which is
there was two very
specific themes that so many of
you are going through.
Number one, everybody wants to
raise money in a world where 80%
of the startups,
especially youngsters I see,
need a business partner
to fill out their operations,
their financials,
their sales, their creative,
so that's number one.
That was a clear
theme and number two,
he was trying to force fit that
he was doing retro gaming and
that's why he should be
in the e-sports game.
That's two different things.
It's hard to date two
people at the same time.
Who is this?
- [Chris] Jo Jo.
- Jo Jo.
(phone ringing)
Getting it going.
- [Jo Jo] Afternoon.
- Jo Jo, this
is Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Jo Jo] What's going on, Gary?
- Life is good, you?
- [Jo Jo] Same old,
working hard.
You know, trying to hustle.
- I get it.
What can I help you with?
- [Jo Jo] So I want to
ask your advice on something.
Let's say you have a
business that was going well.
You built it up from the ground.
Custom clothing
and apparel, you know,
sneakers, hats, all that.
I was getting it on celebrities
and you know I was getting a lot
of shout outs, a lot of tags,
gaining a lot of traction on
Instagram and then
my account got disabled.
- Why? Tell me the truth.
- [Jo Jo] It was the Acceptable
Use Policy and I was going back
and forth with them and I still
haven't gained access to the
account so I also had a personal
account but it wasn't
as big as that one.
So, you know, sales decreased
dramatically and I'm just trying
to gain traction and I wanted
to ask if you had some advice.
It's basically the bulldozer
knocked down my whole business
and without letting
customers know where to go.
You know what I'm saying?
- Hell yeah, I know
what you're saying.
This is why I'm so scared of
everybody building all their
businesses on top of these
platforms and not realizing that
that can happen.
Now, to be very
frank with you, bro,
it's not that
easy to get disabled.
There's plenty of people that
have clothing brands that are
getting shout outs so I don't
know if you got really unlucky
or if there's something you
aren't telling me or if there's
something you
don't know what happened.
But it's not that easy.
Something happened, you know?
I don't know what.
What I would say is this, the
lesson here is you can never be
reliant on just one platform.
It can't just
be about Instagram.
It can't just be about YouTube.
It can't just be
about Twitter, right?
You have to have ways to
communicate with people
outside of just one way.
You need to collect
cell phone numbers.
You need to
collect email addresses.
You need to build up profiles
on all sorts of platforms.
You know, I don't
know what other advice
I could really give you.
I think what you need to do is
go back into the comments of
every shout out you got.
Some of them
probably disappeared.
Some are still there.
Hashtags, truth is
sometimes you just start over.
- [Jo Jo] Yeah. Hmmm.
- I know, listen, send me an
email to Gary@VaynerMedia,
I'll see if I can dig in.
Truth is I don't have any big
relationship with Instagram more
than the next guy.
Maybe I'll take a look but other
than getting it reinstated,
which is hard, 'cause it's a big
company it's not like Zucks is
like yeah, cool, got you.
- [Jo Jo] Yeah.
- I think you got to
restart and be smart.
One thing I think people need to
build up is cell phone numbers,
like do contests, give
people reasons to give you
their cell phone number.
That doesn't go away so easy.
- [Jo Jo] Yeah, I was doing the
whole Mailchimp and everything.
- Good.
- [Jo Jo] So I still
have the email addresses.
- Good.
- [Jo Jo] Getting them
to open an email--
- It's hard, yeah.
Well, give them a reason.
Listen, here's what I would do.
I would send them an email right
now then to everybody and say
look, building
back up my account.
Go follow me
here and doing this.
Giving away 50 hats.
Like give them incentives to get
back into the following of you.
- [Jo Jo] Hmmm, okay.
Alright.
- Alright?
- [Jo Jo] Thank you.
- Good luck, man.
- [Jo Jo] One other question.
- Yeah.
- [Jo Jo] Is the address for
your thing available online
that I can just send you some
gear or how does that work?
- Yes.
It's on VaynerMedia
put it to attention Tyler.
Just put Tyler, that'll work.
He's @Tyler now,
he thinks he's fancy.
Cool, thank you, man.
- [Jo Jo] Appreciate it, man.
- Alright, bye.
Appreciate you, man.
Stay well.
Lesson there, very simple.
Everybody's doing it now,
you can't be reliant on
just one platform.
You know this deja vu 2004,
all my friends hitting me up
like yo, Google fucked me.
They did an algorithm
change I used to be the
first result for hats.
Now I'm page 19,
my business collapsed.
I'm like, yeah.
Build brand,
build other funnels.
You never want to be at the
mercy of a platform's singular
impact on your business.
Now you can also run short
businesses and you extract the
most you can but this is why you
always want to build the biggest
brand, you want to
build multiple things.
I highly recommend all of you
to build out different places.
Who is this?
- [Chris] Ty.
- Ty?
- [Chris] Yeah.
- Build out in different places,
do not be at the
mercy of platforms.
Email and phone
number have been...
- [Ty] Hello?
- Ty?
- [Ty] Yeah.
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk and
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Ty] Holy shit.
- (laughs) Where
you from, brother?
- [Ty] Orlando, Florida.
- Orlando's in the house,
good to see you.
What can I help you with?
- [Ty] I didn't
get that last part.
- What can I help you with?
What can I answer for you?
- [Ty] I'm in high school right
now and I'm like just a hair
away from dropping out and
I really don't know what to do.
- Okay. Well, give
me some more context.
How old are you?
- [Ty] 17.
- Are you in your junior year?
- [Ty] Yes.
- Will your parents
punch you in your face?
- [Ty] Probably.
- And you want
to drop out because?
- [Ty] I just really want to
pursue my business aspirations
but I don't know if my dad
getting on my case about it.
I don't know.
- I hear you.
So, are you good at business?
Are you making money right now?
- [Ty] Yeah, I actually just
opened a Shopify store and
I've been using Facebook ads to
bring in revenue and things are
working out pretty well.
- What are you selling?
- [Ty] Just iPhone
cases right now.
About to start putting
(inaudible) hats on there too.
- So I think the thing that you
need to think about is do you
actually have a, look, dropping
out of high school is pretty
high risk because the world
still gives a shit about that if
you ever have
to get another job.
- [Ty] Yeah.
- Now, if you are willing to eat
shit for the next 12 years and
live with 13 roommates
in a studio in Orlando.
To drop, you know, you know me.
I'm a pure entrepreneur.
I speak very aggressively
against school's value
to real entrepreneurs.
What you got to
promise me Ty is this,
you got to really figure out
if you're a good entrepreneur.
This is a very high risk move.
Like high school,
that's like we're now getting
into no high school diploma.
You're getting into no jobs.
You've got to basically
know at a very young age,
which is very hard at 17,
if you're willing to take this
massive risk because you can't
get a job anywhere that doesn't
pay anything above
minimum wage if you're
unable to be successful.
- [Ty] Yeah, absolutely.
- You know what I'm scared of
and you've heard
me talk about this.
Are you into it because
entrepreneurship is cool now or
were you not breathing
when you were seven and
always wanted to sell Blow Pops?
- [Ty] I mean it
really first started,
I was in middle school
and everybody started smoking
Smarties and my first
instinct was I went to Walmart,
bought a fat ass pack of
Smarties and started selling
Smarties before
I got in trouble.
- Good, that's a good start.
I actually like that.
That means your natural
intuition is to be a sales guy.
Here's what I would say,
listen, nobody hated
school more than me
and I was able to eat that shit.
So, I mean, at some
level, I don't know,
why do you want to quit?
Can't you just mail it in?
They're gonna push you
through the system anyway.
- [Ty] (laughs) I mean,
it wouldn't be dropping out.
It'd be more like
getting my GED. You know?
- But why not just, go have fun
for six hours a day and network
and like do consumer
insights and just do what I do.
I literally did nothing.
I didn't pay attention in class,
I never did homework and I got
F's on all my tests,
they're still gonna push
you through the system.
- [Ty] True. True.
- And then you just go and
you're never gonna be 17 again.
You're never
gonna live in a life,
you drop out now
you've got stress.
You have no fucking stress now.
- [Ty] Yeah.
- You might think Mrs. Thompson
is a pain in the ass.
That ain't shit
compared to real life.
- [Ty] Yeah,
I hear you, I hear you.
- And socially, it's gonna be
more fun if you're in school.
What kind of
grades are you getting?
D's and F's or
you kind of like--
- [Ty] Oh no, I'm doing well.
- Good, get D's and F's.
Here's what I would say,
do fake dropping out.
Get D's and F's.
- [Ty] Okay.
- And use your time
thinking about your business.
I used to read the
Wine Spectator in class.
Like I would just roll into
science class and just
look at your phone when
they're not looking or just
daydream about strategies.
- [Ty] Mhmmm.
- I think there's
just a way to play,
I think there's a way for you
to have your cake and eat it too
where your dad doesn't whip your
and my ass at the same time.
- [Ty] (laughs) Alright, yeah.
I hear that.
- So if you really
want to drop out of school,
the first move is to just really
get bad grades and get through.
- [Ty] Yeah.
- I think you're
just going to the extreme.
- [Ty] Yeah, yeah,
I hear you for sure.
I needed this.
I appreciate it.
- My pleasure, man.
Keep me updated, okay?
- [Ty] Yeah, of course.
- Alright, man.
Take care.
- [Ty] You too.
- And, by the way,
flipping iPhone cases.
It's not a good business.
Like you'll get caught.
The algorithm will change.
You're commoditized.
You're doing sales,
you're not building a business.
Way too many people are getting
confused so understand what that
means and then get back to me
and then we can have
this discussion again.
- [Ty] Okay.
Appreciate it, Gary.
- Cool. Alright, man,
take care, bye bye.
I mean if you told me I was
gonna keep kids in school,
I would have
paid you real money.
Getting soft in my older age.
That was fun.
That was interesting.
Yeah, I think look,
I think what Ty did,
he's a young man but I think
it's a great
way for me to segue.
Obviously, I think I'm finding
my cadence here of giving advice
on top of advice while
we do the phone call thing.
You don't have to go 0 to 100.
This is why I created,
oh, now I can point to it.
In Crush It! I
wrote about 7 P.M.
to 2 in the morning because you
don't have to quit your job to
follow your dream.
You can just quit your
bullshitting and you can quit
your watching TV and quit your
leisure to build your dream.
And so I'm quite practical for
all my insanity and that's the
advice I gave Ty right now.
You don't have to go from doing
pretty well in high school to
dropping out of high school.
Just mail it in.
- [Andy] Adam said you can't use
high school as market research.
(phone ringing)
- Of course you can use high
school as market research.
Sell to the kids
from high school, dick.
Come on.
(phone ringing)
Okay, Adam.
Who's this?
- [Jimena] Hello, Gary?
- This is Gary,
what's your name?
- [Jimena] Hello?
- Hello.
This is Gary, what's your name?
- [Jimena] Oh my God,
I can't believe this.
- You made it.
- [Jimena] Wow, okay.
My name is, I'm so shocked.
My name Jimena.
(inaudible) since
I found you.
Honestly, so shocked.
- Hold on, hold on, let's
calm it down for a second.
Where are you from?
How old are you?
- [Jimena] Sorry, I'm stumbling.
I'm 24. I'm originally
from Venezuela and
I'm currently living in Boston.
- Okay, awesome.
But wait, are
you a Patriots fan?
- [Jimena] No, I'm
not a Patriots fans.
- Okay, good, good, good.
- [Jimena] I like that
they were able to--
- Let's not go any further.
Let's keep going.
- [Jimena] Yeah,
yeah, I know, I know.
No worries.
- What can I help you with?
- [Jimena] Building my second
business trying to connect
teachers from
Venezuela and the U.S.
just trying to help out in
the professional development.
So, let's say that you
were a student were helping,
what classes or what techniques
would you tell teachers to
really use for students?
Concerning many of them are
really very entrepreneurial.
- So, one more time,
help me understand
what business
you're trying to do.
You're trying to sell consulting
or something of that nature?
- [Jimena] No. No, no.
So I'm trying to do a
non-profit in the EdTech space.
- EdTech, got it, okay.
Perfect and so you got a
two-sided marketplace.
Who's the customer
you're trying to reach?
The teacher?
- [Jimena] The client would
end up being not necessarily a
teacher, it would primarily go
through the school and it would
serve as a professional
development course.
- I see.
- [Jimena] It would either
take six months or a year.
- I see.
So are you selling to the
district or the superintendent?
Who are you
selling your EdTech to?
- [Jimena] No, so I'm selling
to a type of school in Venezuela.
- Got it.
- [Jimena] The school districts
in Venezuela are so deteriorated
I wouldn't even attempt them.
- So here's my problem.
The biggest reason I'm
successful is 'cause I day trade
attention and
understand markets.
The truth is I'm so not versed
in the state of private schools
in Venezuela that
I can't reverse engineer
the decision makers.
- [Jimena] No, yeah, so
the question would be is--
- More entrepreneurial
curriculum?
- [Jimena] Yeah, what would you
do for teachers to really learn
more entrepreneurial curriculum?
- I think the problem for me
is, so are you asking about the
curriculum that is
taught to the kids?
- [Jimena] Yes.
- The problem is I don't
know the current state of the
Venezuelan market
'cause I know enough about
the post Hugo Chavez
regime there.
To me, it's tough to
teach entrepreneurship.
So I would never want to teach
entrepreneurship in places that
weren't complete
capitalistic environments
'cause I come from
a Communist country
and I'm scared to give advice
curriculum-wise that wouldn't
bode well for the kids because
they have to navigate
through uncharted waters or
a new regime.
So I'm gonna ask you
'cause you're from there.
Like what's the state of
the union of entrepreneurial
opportunities for people within
that environment that aren't
kick-backing and paying the
government that would shut them
down if they got any leverage?
- [Jimena] Actually, there are
surprisingly enough there are a
ton of entrepreneurs in
Venezuela that aren't necessarily
doing it for the need of
getting food and stuff.
A lot of them have to do with
the social impact space.
- Makes sense.
- [Jimena] Like there's
anti-child in Caracas which
made a huge dent in it.
So what I want to do
is to be able to connect.
Sorry?
- No, I'm listening.
I'm listening.
I'm trying to think on the spot
because it's not, it's cool.
Let me ask you a question, one
of the things that has caught my
attention is how underpriced the
attention on social
networks in Venezuela is.
I would tell you the first, one
of the things I would give a lot
of thought, so do you feel
comfortable building your brand
and putting out
content to that market?
- [Jimena] Yeah because I think
I could find investors that
would really help out.
- I agree.
- [Jimena] So, I'm a
grad student right now.
The only reason I'm really a
grad student was to able to
leave the country simply because
of how deteriorated it was.
- I get it.
- [Jimena] Such a huge level
of people who are trying to--
- The best piece of advice
I could give you is creating
original content to the theory
of this and in specifics and
running ads against individuals
in the marketplace 'cause it's
an underpriced attention
graph on Facebook ads.
- [Jimena] Okay,
thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- [Jimena] I just
want to say, yeah,
so one other thing.
I hustle so much
and I'm so inclined to
make something this company.
I was actually banned from
WeWork for simply being a nice
person and knocking
on people's doors.
- I love it.
- [Jimena] So I just wanted
to say I'm so happy that you
actually answered my call.
I have to thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Have a great day.
- [Jimena] You too.
- God, I love her
passion in her voice.
I think the key, last one,
I think the key in general of
that call for me
is stay in your lane.
As much as I wanted to give her
advice I think that you got to
know where your limits end and
I think knowing the
market is imperative.
I think when
I look at the market,
it's even right now, we're
doing a lot of transcription.
I'm enjoying so much
reading the comments,
I'm hitting the
Facebook Translate.
I'm reading the feedback of all
these different countries 'cause
every market has
it's own nuances.
I've got America mapped.
Intuitively, it's in me.
I'm in it and I can roll and
I think other markets like
U.K. market, western Europe
I feel comfortable but you start
getting into a post dictator,
Socialism regime like Venezuela,
I just don't know
the nuances and so,
you need to be careful when
you're giving advice to stay
within your lane.
(phone ringing)
Stacy? Piece of advice
that a lot of you
need to pay attention to.
Last one. They're here?
- [Stacy] This is Stacy.
- Stacy, this is Gary.
- [Stacy] Hey Gary,
what's going on?
- Life is good, Stace.
How 'bout you?
- [Stacy] Everything's good.
I appreciate you on
so many different levels.
I think you have the blueprint
on so many different things,
that's why I had to talk to you.
- Well, thank you.
Where are you from?
- [Stacy] I'm from Vegas.
I live in Las Vegas right now.
- Love it. What
can I help you with?
- [Stacy] Couple questions,
I have been hustling in all
different realms from
dealing with texts to,
pardon me.
- No worries.
- [Stacy] Startup
techs, e-commerce,
ex-college athlete all of that
and I know it's preparing me to
kind of have success in the
way I'm going so I started my
marketing company to help small
businesses in regard to their
social media presence
and really try to help them
to the next level.
- Okay.
- [Stacy] But then I hear
you every single day,
people need to
fall in love with you,
people need to fall
in love with the brand.
So I'm gonna do exactly that.
From my business,
my success, my failures.
I've had success when I was
young and I didn't have the
model in place to
kind of maintain that.
- Yep.
- [Stacy] So, this time around
I kind of want to share my
journey with people.
- Understood.
- [Stacy] Do you
suggest I do something else?
How would you try to plug
that in to kind of help me
along my journey?
- Meaning how do you
interweave your journey?
- [Stacy] Correct.
- So what platform are you
communicating on as a human?
- [Stacy] Instagram
and I'm gonna be
starting my YouTube channel.
- Right, so that part where you
said I'm gonna be starting my,
that's the part
we need to address.
You don't need a DRock.
Your DRock is your phone.
You need to start creating.
- [Stacy] Yes sir.
- That's it.
It's not crazy, Stace.
It's so crazy, right?
But the answer is of course.
You've been hearing me.
The blueprint I have is free.
You know it already.
- [Stacy] Mhmmm.
- You just got to do it.
So the answer is yes.
Do I think you and by
the way, even Instagram,
if you just did Instagram you
can use your Instagram account
to do your content and your
marketing and you can use your
Instagram Stories
to be your vlog.
It's incredible we
have so many tools.
We're so goddamn lucky, Stace.
- [Stacy] I know.
- You and I are doing a drive
time radio show right now that
would've cost millions
of dollars to distribute
just 20 years ago.
I'm holding up some weird
fucking phone and Other Tyler's
got a camera here.
There's forty
live streams going on.
Like we're living
in unprecedented times.
You just have to do.
- [Stacy] I appreciate that.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- Do you agree?
I'm trying to
read your reaction.
- [Stacy] No, no I said
I appreciate you so much.
- No, I heard that.
- [Stacy] I've read every book.
I see every live stream.
Yes, it's in the process.
- But that, you
know what I mean?
You don't need
to order jack shit.
Fuck a fucking camera.
Fuck lighting,
you've got a phone.
- [Stacy] Okay.
- Stace, what I'm scared of is
everybody's reading my books and
watching everything and
reading, everybody's motivated.
Everybody's
ordering the equipment.
You know who I'm always scared
that all my followers are?
You ever see that guy who buys
Roger Federer's sneakers and
wristbands and he's got $800
racket and he's got the headband
and the water bottle
and he drinks the $8 fuckin'
electrolytes coconut water and
he stretches for 15 minutes and
then he goes on the
court and he loses 6-Love?
- [Stacy] (laughs) Yeah.
- That's what I'm scared of.
What winners do, which
is put in the practice.
I want you to take the tennis
ball and hit it against the wall
'cause that's all you've got.
A shitty racket and your wall
and you just keep hitting it
over and over and over again.
- [Stacy] Yes sir, absolutely.
- I still don't believe you.
I don't believe that I'm gonna
hang up and you're gonna do it.
- [Stacy] I'm going
to get my son.
- What's your Instagram account?
What is your Instagram account?
- [Stacy] S-T-A-C-P-E-N-A.
Stac Pena.
- Great. I'm gonna
keep an eye on you.
- [Stacy] Absolutely.
- Don't let me down.
- [Stacy] I'm on it, I promise.
- Do not let the Vayner Nation
down 'cause they will go on
your, they will troll the
shit out of you in a week.
- [Stacy] I'm there.
I got you, I promise.
- Good luck.
- [Stacy] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Question of the day:
How many of you are
that bullshit tennis player?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)